hey youtubers is charlie so Zack Snyder
posted this behind-the-scenes teaser for
Batman V Superman and Justice League
it's mostly a Justice League teaser and
I know it doesn't seem like much but
there's a whole lot going on in that
picture so let's break it down the very
first thing that everybody zeroed in on
was the flash costume in the back look
how shiny look how shiny if you didn't
know Ezra Miller's concept art has been
out for a while they released it during
that Batman vs Superman Suicide Squad
special that they had a couple weeks ago
that geoff johns and kevin smith did the
Flash movie itself is still a long ways
off it's going to happen a long time
after Justice League it is Remillard has
to appear as the Barry Allen flash in
Justice League so that's why they need
this suit and really that's what you
should take to heart when you're looking
at all the things inside this frame all
these pieces of costumes in various
states of production are mostly relative
to the Holy Trinity like really I feel
like the only things going on in this
picture are Aquaman things that there's
a lot of new Aquaman stuff we haven't
seen much of him yet but we have seen
his costume in concept art so it's not
that big a surprise some wonder woman
stuff some Batman stuff now I'm really
seeing any Superman stuff but it might
just be behind Jason Momoa here he and
Zack Snyder standing in front of some
dummies with costumes on it so we don't
know what's behind them let's just go
back to front through the image here we
have Ezra Miller's flash costume what
looks like jason momoa Aquaman armor
then a black suit that looks like it's
just an upgraded version of Batman suit
without the symbol on it and a lot of
people were wondering if this as
Nightwing we haven't seen Nightwing or
any reference to him in the universe
they wouldn't spoil it in an image like
this so this is probably just a Batman
suit there's a little green in between
them here there might be some green
lantern somewhere in this workshop he
has to appear in Justice League
somewhere which is like the flash movie
The Green Lantern's movie remember it's
plural Green Lantern's is way far off in
the distance and we don't even know
which Green Lantern's are gonna include
I mean we kind of know because it's
going to be all the marquee ones but
there'll be multiple Green Lantern's and
as I set that up during Justice League
then moving over to the right it looks
like more Aquaman maybe some Wonder
Woman stuff actually I didn't mention it
like way back at the back it looks like
there's some Wonder Woman concept art
here we'll get a better look at her
costume in the Wonder Woman movie but
remember Justice League is the next step
up so I'm expecting everybody to look
that much more badass like get upgraded
armor slightly different versions of
their suits for justice league that's
why they
this is a bad suit like he has the cloth
suit and Batman V Superman in the giant
suit of armor for fighting Superman I
think this is more of a compromised tech
suit something that's a little bit
heavier but not like walking around in a
giant tank this helmet might be a Wonder
Woman helmet or it could be something
from Aquaman's universe if it is from
the Aquaman universe it could be one of
the Atlantean helmets but I think all
the things that we're seeing in this
picture here are Justice League specific
to the Holy Trinity with the exception
of the flash suit so this is probably
part of Wonder Woman's armor there's an
edit of the Batman cowl and this hasn't
appeared in any of the trailers but they
did say Batman's voice changer is in his
cow when he's wearing the cowl it
automatically changes his voice he's not
doing the voice Christian Bale style
this armor on the right looks like it
might be Wonder Woman's I know in the
last 10 to 15 years they change wonder
woman's character a lot she's gone from
warrior two more of a diplomat they
tried to weave in more of a Greek
mythology aspect to it but remember DC
is rebooting well not necessarily
rebooting but it's redoing all of its
titles this summer pretty much every
single major title major character is
getting a rebirth so it's going to start
with rebirth number one the only comics
that they're changing in a different way
our action comics and detective comics
like their longest-running titles those
will go back to the old numbering system
it's kind of complicated I think they've
been disappointed with the weight comics
have been selling recently and they want
to take advantage of the movies that are
coming out this year they have Batman V
Superman Suicide Squad so they want to
get that movie audience start buying
comics in the same way marvel did when
the Marvel movies blew up so there is
anything that's relevant to the movies
or the TV shows or anything like that I
will totally do videos for the new
comics but just to reiterate most of the
stuff you see in this picture here is
probably Holy Trinity related for
justice league no idea what's behind
Jason Momoa though there could be some
green lantern or some other special
stuff hidden behind him but make no
mistake this is not an accidental
picture they didn't just say hey why
don't we do this is to be fun I would
not be surprised if they are
intentionally blocking something behind
them with their bodies let me know in
the comments though do you really like
when directors drop teases like this I
mean it's not a trailer it's not
traditional marketing but I think it's a
lot of fun because it gives you the
opportunity to see some of the stuff
they're working on like hey look at this
awesome stuff we're working on you can
make some guesses as to what they're
showing and it prevents them from having
to release the entire movie before the
actual movie comes out but in that same
vein there's a whole
bunch of new images for Captain America
Civil War so I'll do a video on that
next it might not post till tomorrow
morning but be sure to subscribe to get
everything if there's any justice league
or Batman V Superman stuff you guys want
me to do just let me know in the
comments that movie is coming really
soon and I don't give a lot of credence
to the rumors that Warner Brothers are
super worried about it the real reason I
think Zack Snyder posted this picture
now is because they're getting ready to
shoot Justice League in April in if they
were so worried about Batman V Superman
they would push the start date of
Justice League since they haven't I feel
like it's evidence that they feel
totally fine about the movie anybody who
spends three hundred million dollars
making a movie and marketing it is going
to feel a little bit worried so while
you guys wait for a new captain america
civil war to post you can click here for
my Star Wars music behind-the-scenes
video this is a new Easter eggs and you
can click here to learn all about Harley
Quinn in the Suicide Squad movie thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight